Good morning John, it’s Wednesday. I’m
in bed because I feel really bad. Yesterday
I felt fine at 8 o’clock and then by 9 o’clock
I had a 101 degree fever and a sore throat
and a sinus headache and all of my skin hurt
to touch, so I felt like not having anything
touch me.
Then I wanted to go to bed so I did. And then
I woke up about 25 different times because
I was having the same dream over and over
again about having to build a satellite of
Lego pieces with an incompetent team of jerks
who didn’t know how to build a satellite.
It was really embarrassing that our satellite
was so bad. And I had that dream all night
long, the same dream, over and over again,
and I really didn’t like it, and I had to
pee a lot.
I did get my computer so that I could be awake
and do things while in bed. I love that you
can do that nowadays. You can totally be a
productive citizen without ever having to
leave your bed.
I watched episodes of Tiny Toon Adventures
which I love that show, so I came to have
the fun with Yakko, Wakko and Dot and Bu-Babs
and Buster Bunny and Pinky and The Brain,
and this is a... stuffed animal that I was
cuddling with.
Why is it a strike when you miss the ball?
In baseball why isn’t it... you strike,
like if I strike you, you don’t say I struck
you if I missed. It doesn't make any sense.
And I also spent some time exploring Your
Pants, and I found some of my favorite threads
in the history of all forums ever. Like this
one that you can click in the doobly-doo about
how, uh, sciency people to blow minds. It’s
great. And then this one, there was a thread
for people from Palestine and people from
Israel and then the people in those in that
thread decided that they should collaborate
and be one thread. Middle East peace in Your
Pants.
And I also really liked this one in which
people talk about how they became nerdfighters.
Everybody finds these videos a different way,
and there’s a million billion ways to do
it and there’s one person for every way
to do it cause there’s a million billion
of you. Hi!
Sometimes I feel like we’ve been unfair
to the giraffes, John. I think that we can
make it up to them.
Additionally, I have some great news if you
live in Seattle or Portland, I am going to
be in Seattle or Portland next month, Marchy
times, and I don’t know exactly when but
I’ll put the information in the describy
boob.
Uuuuuuuooghuuhhh. I’m gonna go to bed. John,
I’ll see you on Fridaaaay. Uuuuuuuhhh.